can I be honest with you what I'm not
kidding at 51 and I'm 51 yeah that's
right good round fifty I could
roundhouse you in the side of your head
and knock you the [ __ ] out you know you
would break your ankle gnaw on my head
even if I was turning around like this
like boo and you hit me here see my
roundhouse and it would change the way
you walk for the rest of time no my
rawness is stupid now yeah yeah I get my
shoulders into it a lot of people think
it's in the leg I bring my shoulders
around and then my hips and my my foot
is basically just there with the legs a
ball rubber band with a with a stone at
the end of it yeah it's a rubber band my
legs a rubberband and I got a stone for
a foot and it's gonna go and it doesn't
clang off your head it goes right
through oh really you're like Mike Tyson
you you aim to the other side of the
eyes I finished I finished that cut
through yeah well you know you talk a
lot of [ __ ] and you talk a lot of game
when you come at me and I [ __ ] beg
yeah I beg you to try thank you I want I
want to be holding that I had at that
award in the other in one hand and I'll
just be sizing you up with one hand I
got the award in the other hand and
you'll be you'll be pretty timid to go
swinging your legs this way in that
exposing that sweet sweet balloon knot
of yours cuz I'll get this right through
your [ __ ] that man how much stitching
you got in your jeans no just go read by
the way might might Taekwondo teacher
who was a Korean guy who who was boxed
and did judo black belt judo and a real
fighter
and this bodybuilder came in to our
studio and he he looked at him and I
said how do you fight a guy like that
and he said I said good as a trampoline
very good trampoline and I said as I
made as the temple means a very nice
good muscles I'm jumping bong bong I'm
wrong and he said in other words I'll
knock him out and just jump on him like
a trampoline until he [ __ ] dies what
that was my career what martial arts
discipline is that well he was you know
technically Taekwondo but he knew
rattling dozer Locker
never thought of that okay your fare
like wordplay I like to [ __ ] around I
want to ask you a question well I want
to get I want to get serious I heard a
there is this all this new
port about how you don't have to have a
concussion to have CTE that's so now
this doctor who did the main Doctor Who
seizure and concussion said I don't
think any there should be any contact
sports for any kids until they're 18
years old now here's my question you
played contact sports you are and and
I'm not saying this to be a dick but
you're a [ __ ] idiot right no I'm not
saying but if you ask if you do a
consensus he's a good guy
he's good guy talented guy but he's a
[ __ ] idiot right hold that rage now
who knows how much of that let you
finish your point who knows how much
you're like [ __ ] your daily [ __ ]
is is a result of head injury we don't
know we can't measure it right now the
daily [ __ ] we're just you walk
around like no I'm gonna push that guy
and then I'm gonna go bad you know you
know what I mean and that's trying to
fall I'm trying to fall not trying to be
a dick but but no well you would admit
that you're a [ __ ] idiot but not
exact I'm a [ __ ] idiot for the most
part if you're like getting me a little
bit on the audience Network who [ __ ]
cares that's what I mean well that's
that like I don't give a sh that's an
abrasive what you do nobody cares
right well you know right I'll be the
first to die [ __ ] you could put your
bag over there but I'm gonna bring it
really close to my knee and crowd myself
in and drink 17 [ __ ] gallons of all
kinds of liquor I wanted to give you
your gift yeah but you're a [ __ ]
idiot no I'm not a [ __ ] idiot video
like I who played contact sports do you
think we should ban contact sports first
of all I learnt about this stuff first
of all I'd like to take ownership some
of the things that you've said yeah and
I know that when it comes to my career
and what I've helped create and what
I've been fortunate enough to be a part
on I take it easy don't get emotional no
I'd say ninety-seven and ninety-eight
percent of that has been total [ __ ]
now alright so I understand how can you
say like okay Loudermilk well look I
just took I just don't be that hard on
yourself not 98 percent of it you said
they didn't work I flicked the barbs off
of your insult now I'd like to continue
Loudermilk is a quality [ __ ] show
okay okay and if you speak ill of it one
more
time I'm gonna put that up
don't say the award again with my
balloon not I don't it already hurts
just the thought I don't and I that's
because I seems that's because of the
seams look how wide that gentleman is
you're gonna start a fight as elbows in
a physical fight on there if you keep
talking I think we could all agree if I
turn that upside down injury if I turn
that upside down yeah it would hurt a
whole lot more okay when I inserted
don't do that I think that I went and
saw did you see concussion 2 3 years ago
whenever we saw it I lived it I have a
black belt in Taekwondo he's going and I
wrestled anyway so yeah dad played some
contact sports I was you know I was
mostly dishing it out rather than
receiving it you know an object in
motion tends to stay in motion
and when that object is a is a is a high
school phenom don't say phenom we're an
angry boy with a lot with a problem 310
pounds of solid brick it wasn't all
brick well yeah it was no blue no clue
how to eat what's protein what's a
Republican no idea you stayed at all I
just said it all I got it down there and
I did some bench pressing I did some
deep deep deep removing some weight with
high school yeah yeah yeah I did some
powerlifting and stuff would you bench
in high school oh you want to know what
my you'd be honest max
yeah Malcolm max will be talking like
cuz like I usually like to throw ate up
and I go like that's where I'm at
you throw what up eight reps yeah
alright well that's fine
I usually sometimes and we're like you
know we're doing I mean it's high school
you know yeah but we were all
powerlifting and doing like city
competitions yeah City competition some
of my buddies yes sure yeah so you know
I don't have some weight I wanted people
to come out of the room going you
wouldn't [ __ ] believe what's a so is
pushing up and they're just like running
through the halls going yeah you know
yeah
bench yeah backs max and don't be just
now you don't have to search for it cuz
you know and yeah a little tendinitis in
my right now so I'm not sure if I could
do this to this day but well I'm asking
what you did in high school and you know
the number so and I don't appreciate the
pause because you're looking around six
hundred forty pounds that's not true
we'll know don't shrug your shoulders
now no you can't just go no hey that'd
be a rose for your listeners who can't
see me doing this right now the the you
know the audio equivalent is this well
see yeah I know yeah I know and and and
because you did a sport tell me I didn't
bench press six hundred forty pounds
eight times eight hey will you 100
percent and definitely very obviously
without a question
didn't bench 640 pounds when you're in
high school or ever eight times mmm okay
see see see what I mean yeah
so what did you bench oh I know I didn't
bench 640 pounds eight times yeah or I
rather that wasn't my max cuz I benched
at eight times my max max was 885 panel
see that would be a world record
basically and look up look it up in the
Canadian annex of sporting feats go to
go to the Canadian app please go to a
Phoenix of sporting feats dot see a dot
see a guide Canadian annex of sporting
feats feats yep well yeah if you just
put that yeah let's see it let's see
what it comes out there fifteen biggest
moments in Canadian sports are you up in
that I'm sure I'm number one read number
one that's guy I've not seen this
article yet but number one yep alright
here we go
biggest things the urge to make less
runs deep alright come on this is gonna
be a gene to pal Vince Carter always the
slam dunk contest Wow who gives I all
right that's a sporting feet what
happened on the all-star week or other
curler captures Olympic gold look what
hey I'm from Canada and this is a
piss-poor [ __ ] list alright just get
to number one
all right well swims Lake Ontario okay
Chuvalo goes the distance with Olli you
didn't win hi bro you went the distance
so Canadian today just to just survive
take second yeah second he [ __ ] he
was in there like a bag of meat Canadian
woman takes 1928 Olympics by storm that
was only a hundred and fifty five years
ago Gretzky to Lemieux yeah blah blah
everything Gretzky ever did yeah yeah
yeah alright Mike Weir wins the master
don't know what any of that means keep
going Barbara head Scott takes
Sage's gold that's a big who gives a
[ __ ] Wayne Gretzky again because it's
traded LA yeah leaving Canada was a big
moment in Canadian sport area Fox
Business cross Canada that's the only
good one that one should be number one
if it's not me for a moment
a hundred meter go a guy with shoulders
like like ripe Halloween pumpkins yes
filled with gas yeah on roids yes one
something for a few minutes and that's
Sidney Crosby scores the golden goal
whatever lots of those have happened the
Blue Jays went back to back World Series
Wow
all-american number two Donovan Bailey
Sprint's to golden Atlanta that was
pretty cool yeah that was pretty good
Olympic athletes are black oh that one
poor Canada great
in 1993 Will Sasso I don't see that 640
Penn I know where is that where he
reminds where are you easy friends I'm
looking at the website oh my god y'all
have no SATs was just a stage thing Paul
Henderson was my I was my name in hi
Scott at a lien or any of that [ __ ] Will
Sasso yeah oh yeah so but I could get to
you know what I wanted to do when I
moved to Hollywood wife I want to get
this part you can't park here I'm tell
you this right now yeah yeah yeah yeah
watch your tongue oh good what's gonna
happen what are you gonna do use some of
that boxing you've been doing
[Laughter]